good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having a great day hi jackie
how are you hi claudia i'm doing well
thank you and that is because it's
thursday and we're officially over the
hump we are sliding into the weekend and
this week for me was one of those weeks
at the beginning of the week where i was
like
i am so excited for this week to be over
i have so much to do this week and so
once it's
friday night like all will be done and
it's friday night you're a small town
girl everything is right and we rule the
world i've just been like having
this joie de vivre like all week like i
can't explain like not to be so annoying
the hairstyle no
i'm telling you there's a correlation i
think it's a hairstyle i think it's also
kind of like not to blame you know put
all my troubles on the olympics but like
i just feel this weight lifted off of me
and i just feel lighter than ever um
even though i've never weighed more and
it's just so exciting you know i feel
like
i've just been in a good mood all week i
can't wait to like for it to run out i
was due for a good mood because the two
weeks before like i was on my period and
sick and i was an absolute not here
because like you have to contain my
composure but like in private behind
closed doors like i was an
absolute monster damn so i was due for
some good energy who do you think
received the monstrosity the worst ben
or theo i would literally never direct
any morsel of anger towards theo 100 to
ben and honestly the fact that i stand
here today making it through that
two-week period still a married woman
is
it's god it's really it's all in his
hands wow that's beautiful thank you um
how are you doing i'm good i'm actually
really excited because the new episode
of the redheads dropped i hear it's
quite divisive it is so divisive so
there are people we read the book all
four of us
half the group would say one of the
books best books they ever read the
other half would say the worst book they
ever read which is just so crazy so we
are really getting into everything like
there's a lot of strong opinions on the
episode
which always makes for a great episode
so if you read the book check it out if
you didn't read the book you can still
listen to the episode because there's a
summary and it's just like a really
funny episode but it's never too late to
become a redhead snitch announced her
choice and it's actually like not that
smitchy it's not a why a it's not a why
a it's it's a novel
it's novel it's a snovel it's called we
are the brennans and i read the synopsis
it looks really good i'm really excited
to read it you're telling me snitch
chose a non-young adult
like love story yeah coming-of-age
that dana could have chosen
so it's not a coming-of-age story it
might be it might be a coming-of-age
story but it's not boy meets girl
boy girl gets murdered like
girl comes back as a ghost literally to
have the best sex of her life
no it's not that but i'm really excited
to read her choice we also all shared
the other books that we read this month
which is actually my favorite segment
where we just get to talk about books
books and i really love the book clara
and the sun i thought it was such an
interesting read um i love clara i don't
know if i told you this but to me the
reason why the book resonated with me so
much is because did you choose this one
dana chose it was like extremely
literary won the nobel peace prize
um
i loved this book because to me at the
heart of it it was about cameras and
counselors
and what hurt the most was that
counselor couldn't see that so is it
possible though that the book was not
very good but you were blinded by the
camper counselor energy
it's not possible that the book wasn't
good because this author is like
uh you know
worldwide socrates yeah yeah so it's
good it's just i feel like if they
didn't really like it it's because they
didn't get it but you know socrates is a
relative term because like for me i
would say like colleen hoover is a
socrates you know yeah she is so like if
colleen whoever wrote a book and some
people said it was really bad you'd be
like you just don't get it well no
actually that's the thing about books
they're so subjective they are which is
so crazy even in the comments section
i'm waiting to hear what the redhead
readers thought about the book because i
need more opinions but even in the
comments section on our post
the comments are this was the best book
i ever read or the worst book i couldn't
finish it i feel like that's always the
case you know yeah that is true
nothing's universal is there one book
out there that everyone can agree so
amazing
probably like romeo and juliet
i don't know if you had to sit down and
read romeo and juliet right now because
you wouldn't be able to finish it i feel
like one of fahrenheit 451 one of the
most popular books of the last like two
three years was where the crawdad sing
but there are some people who couldn't
finish it well of course like we're all
humans we all have different interests
so like no one not everyone is gonna
love one book even though i have heard
that um i actually haven't heard anyone
who didn't like girls don't drop the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster yeah i haven't heard
anyone either just read my amazon
reviews because they've all been taken
out
kidding they've all been murdered
no actually
i haven't heard anyone who didn't like
it ends with us by colleen hoover which
we talked about on the episode because i
read it this month yeah i guess the only
thing i've heard about that book is that
like because it's so hyped up was that
like i mean the ending is really crazy
but like when you hype something up so
much you can really only go down yeah so
the only kind of complaint i've heard
from people who read it after the hype
is like
not worth the height so much hype but
like if they just read it because they
stumbled upon it would have been like a
life-changing book it was a
life-changing book for me yeah do you
want to know something crazy like there
are people who don't like evelyn hugo
who didn't like it who like rebecca
didn't
rebecca
hold on
i'm allergic to the disgusting nature of
this conversation i know you didn't like
evelyn hughes is that crazy there are
people who didn't like evelyn hugo so
that just goes to show i've actually
been on this journey that i want to
explain to you and like you i feel like
you can help me figure it out okay so
whenever i've actually been really
diving into taylor swift's
ever more album and i was just having a
conversation with my friend abe about
how like i think it's better than
folklore
and whenever i am reading it i mean
whenever i'm listening to it especially
champagne problems
i really like can't stop thinking about
evelyn hugo and i can't decide if that's
because i read the book when we were in
utah evermore had just come out i was
listening to evermore a lot or because i
think a lot of the songs i think a lot
of evelyn hugo is drawing inspiration
from taylor swift and i think a lot of
the songs draw inspiration from the book
if that makes sense okay i think your
first point is probably the most
the fact that when you if you listen to
it while you were reading a certain book
the the soundtrack will always remind
you of that book okay but usually that
does fade if the two aren't really
congruent no there's someone dropped
your hand while dancing the champagne
problems is so about cecilia and evelyn
yeah like remember spoiler alert they're
at the concert and like holding hands
and then someone sees him dropped your
hand while dancing
left you out there
it's so about evelyn and cecilia don't
come for me it could be it really could
be
but also i think that
and i don't know if this is true but
taylor jenkins reed
must have found inspiration in taylor
swift like the seven husbands of elvin
hugo the million boyfriends of taylor
swift there are conspiracy theories that
taylor you know i'm just saying
i she's never mentioned it really like i
don't watch all of her interviews but
like i've never even seen a threat of
that really oh man in my mind it was
like the seven husbands of evelyn you go
like that's like elizabeth taylor
it's not elizabeth taylor swift no i
think it's elizabeth taylor
um whatever well we have a great show
for you guys today fast five actually
some interesting things to talk about
finally and we have uh tv recap real
housewives of beverly hills was on last
night quite a divisive episode yeah and
i mean the fast five i feel as though
they're gonna be fast because it's just
some
some news and i need to talk about real
housewives of beverly hills until the
cows come home because i need to we need
to get to the bottom of this you and i
and um love island was on last night i
know you didn't watch and i'm so glad
you didn't because i know how precious
your time is
is it definitely skip episode because
the families are on zoom right and the
whole there's no real couples there so
it's like who are you meeting i mean new
friends we'll talk about it it's so it
was silliness okay but i'm ready to dive
in i really don't have much else to say
i'm ready to dive in as well just check
out the redheads another great episode
from the girls and
it's never too late so without further
do where are you not here because we
have meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcast podcast it is time for the five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
sorry and today's episode is brought to
you by oh my god my curds are
alpha-clamped your curds
okay
today's episode is brought to you by
coors pure organic do you ever feel like
living a balanced life is hard like you
try super hard to keep up with what's
considered balance you push yourself
each and every day getting better and
better but it can be overwhelming
you work out daily eat healthy 100 of
the time keeping up with all the
wellness trends you feel like you're
trying to work so hard all the time
enter coors pure organic but chill about
it new course pure is a refreshingly
simple beer with organic barley organic
hops and water at 92 calories and zero
sugar it's the perfect beer to celebrate
the wins of everyday life because
sometimes like having a beer shouldn't
be such a burden you know and i really
believe that coarse pure is taking the
burden out of beer they should use that
for a slogan um they're all about
promoting balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes so
whether you gotta run in or you just got
as far as putting on your running shoes
of course pure is here to celebrate you
um it's just perfect for like a light
especially in the summer it's a
delightful beer that i think everyone
enjoy will enjoy it feels better
drinking it it's less heavy it's the
perfect beer to celebrate the winds of
everyday life so when you want to enjoy
a beer with without the guilt reach for
coors pure it's organic but chill about
it go to coorspure.com
toast to see where you can find coors
pure
thank you claudia a pleasure thank you
cordia cordia
first story heidi montag says lauren
conrad's career should have been more
successful heidi montag thinks her
former tv foe lauren conrad should have
been much more successful in her career
she quipped during a new interview on
call her daddy that lauren should have
gone on to become the most successful
hills alum but quote she is not where
she should be at all these days she said
heidi said kristen let's be honest is
the most successful while lauren's net
worth is reportedly valued at 40 million
thanks to multiple fashion lines a
beauty brand and nine books montag
believes her former co-star should have
been as successful as billionaire kylie
jenner she said i feel like lauren
didn't make it like she should have she
should be kylie she was so good at
makeup she should have done the
tutorials if she had a good team she'd
be a billionaire she'd be a hundred
millionaire she is not where she should
have been at all she continued saying
quote she has a kohl's line great
whatever but she should be a hundred
million that's like saying she has a
gold bar whatever like
kohl's lines
literally the most rich sofia vergara
j-lo it's the best thing it's better
than having a line of chanel like it's
so mass-produced didn't elizabeth and
james just go exclusively to kohl's for
mary kate and ashley it's nothing to
snuff at no it's not she said are you
kidding she said are you kidding me who
gets that big promotion that big fame
that big engine behind her the loved one
this and that the narrator no one even
gets the narrator show kylie didn't get
a narrator show she should be so rich
okay i have a lot of thoughts and first
of all i just really liked that alex
asked this question like she's like well
what do you think lauren made her money
and she bounced and like she lives a
very and she doesn't have to do the
hills reboot like it was a good question
um and i just want to preface by saying
i really do like spencer and heidi like
i think the comeback they've made when
they were like hated when they didn't
even do anything which is like a stupid
tv show that was scripted like i think
they're great
but
this does just give off like bitter
vibes because
okay could lauren have become a
billionaire maybe maybe but she's
a 40 millionaire like that's nothing
to scoff at scoff out like i was
supposed i said snuff before that's not
the right word it's something to scoff
at especially because i don't think
that's an entirely accurate
representation and it's entirely
possible and i think that heidi and
spencer and admit their they'll admit
themselves are so fame driven whereas
like lauren was not like how many people
can go from being exactly the narrator
beloved by the world to be living a
completely private life like we know
nothing about lauren so i think that
that's probably well still having an
outward-facing brand like her brand
still relies on her celebrity but she
doesn't even act as a celebrity maybe if
she was out there on all these reboots
thirsting it up her brand would be
bigger but maybe she's like i'd rather
have the 40 million and peace of mind
than have 100 million and be thirsty and
desperate like some other people right
so i think that the decision lauren made
is that was actually
the best one but i just think if like if
heidi and spencer had been in that
position they would have done it
completely differently and i don't think
that if lauren had tried to become the
next kylie she would have like if lauren
was out here doing makeup tutorials like
i don't think at all
that that's
that's what would have happened yeah i
agree it wasn't the the same it's
they're not on the same timeline so you
can't say like she should have been
doing makeup tutorials because it was
still a little 20 years ago early for
stuff like that um also yes lauren was
the narrator of this highly popular mtv
show but like kylie is a kardashian like
it's just so different i know i actually
think that i think that wasn't a
terrible reference only in the sense
that at the height of the hills they
were as famous as the kardashians
are now yes but in a time where it was
harder to monetize your digital
following yes it didn't exist 100
so i just think and first the thing that
i just disagreed with the most about
most about this interview is kind of the
toss away comment about kohl's what it's
like
brands like that that's how jessica
simpson built a billion dollar brand
it's it's hers at cole's i was thinking
that too start at home i don't know but
i was going to mention jessica simpson
so if we both have the same thought then
it there's something well it's if it's
on kohl's it's a similar brand and like
she had runs a billion dollar business
her business did over a billion dollars
in sales so
just like the kind of like it's only at
kohl's it's
that's the best kind of deal you can
have it's so mass market is it the
fanciest no but you're getting your
clothes into literally millions of
people's homes
and that's the best thing you can have
so she only has a line of coals that's
give me a line of coals like that's the
best thing so many celebrities have it
and it's if they make more money from it
than they do like their music jlo has it
sofia vergara has it everyone has it
yeah it's just really crazy that this is
heidi's take but i have to believe this
is how like her and spencer sleep at
night like
because lauren got so much from the show
and just was able to exit whereas i
don't even think spencer and heidi would
ever want to exit they like being public
figures but they also like being rich
right so they're probably just like well
lauren doesn't have it that good it's
only 40 million right but like they've
also been really open about the fact how
like they made a ton of money after the
hills and then they went almost broke
because they spent like millions of
dollars on crystals right so i think
that like money and fame are so equally
important to them and they're like shook
by lauren who so happily gave up the
fame and also with that fame could have
been more money it could have been 400
million but like for lauren having a
normal life a husband kids and 40
million dollars was enough for her you
know what i also i just don't agree with
the idea that she could have been a
billionaire because like from the hills
we have two successful
household brand names and that's lauren
and kristen
and i think kristen has done everything
right also while also not shying away
from the wheels yeah and she did very
cavalry like and she's always you know
out putting herself out there and her
instagram is like you know she's an
influencer and she ended up with 30
million okay i have a question
so when when you say lauren i mean
kristin's success do you mean fame or
money
both
okay because
like the elephant in the room is that uh
doesn't a lot a large part of chris and
cavalier's net worth come from her
husband so we're just talking about
business okay
let's let's cause she said kristen's the
richest one which might be true because
of jay got it okay but let's just take
jay out of it like i think kristin has
done so many things right when it comes
to her business and when it comes to
fame right and still the cap would be
max 30 million right i think heidi's
overestimating
the ubiquitous popularity of this show
yes
as we move further away from the initial
show right i'm sure for them it feels
like this was like
everything and for us it was everything
and for a certain section of the
population like we loved the hills yeah
but most people like the majority of
people grown people did
well also another thing that she spoke
about in the interview which i did find
really interesting was um
i haven't re-watched the hills and of
course i'm so team lc like it's in my
blood but i do think if i rewatched it
like i might have like a more mature
perspective like okay you didn't like
spencer like did you have to write off
and i do think in a lot of ways like
spencer and heidi were given the short
end of the stick and she does talk about
her relationship with elsie how like at
times elsie treated her like a dog like
because elsie brought her on the show
and that means she had to like sing for
her supper and like do whatever lauren
wanted which is like not the way a
friendship works so i do think that that
part of the interview was really
interesting and i do have like a lot of
grace i think for spencer and heidi
because i do feel like they were painted
as these villains on a show that was
somewhat scripted
that now like in hindsight it was such a
big deal like they moved into their
apartment like they didn't like kill
anyone like they just like had a toxic
relationship but now the proof is in the
pudding like was it toxic they've been
married for
over 10 years yeah so i do feel like
that's a really interesting part of the
conversation too but i think naturally
she's probably
bitter i would be too like
you get painted as a villain and lauren
gets to like get this perfect life and
they're still you know doing reboots of
the hills yeah and lauren doesn't have
to do that
right but it's like heidi
i think in truth like it's it's nice
that lauren doesn't have to do that but
heidi's almost faulting her for not
working harder yes but it's not about
work it's about fame yeah no and it's
just about like
what kind of life you want to have you
know no and by the way you can live an
amazing like the most amazing life if
you are worth 40 million dollars and to
not have to deal with the
mental
health element of being famous it's
it's brilliant when people aren't big
enough
to see it that way they're like okay i
could be 500 million and i just have to
do more red carpets and go here and
there and do interviews and put myself
out there and like open myself up to all
this criticism
most people wouldn't make the choice
that lauren made most people wouldn't
make the choice to leave fame behind
when you have fame so good it's easy to
not want to be famous anymore when
you're spencer and heidi and everyone
hates you imagine making the choice to
leave the limelight when you are
universally beloved yeah can't relate
can't really that's the crazy part of
this whole thing like i could unders i
could have understood if we never heard
from spencer and heidi ever again after
the hills they were scarred by the fame
by the scrutiny by the criticism and
lauren went on to have a million other
shows but for lauren to have made the
decision to walk away from fame when she
literally had every opportunity
laying at her feet that's the crazy part
yeah and that's like the admirable part
yeah so i
love spencer and heidi and i don't fault
them for thinking how they think because
they must be in in a lot of ways
traumatized like from that experience
yeah
but i don't agree with this call at all
and justice for calls justice for calls
and justice for 40 million dollars yeah
like it's a lot and also your net worth
does not mean how much money you have in
the bank so
i don't think i should right but also
like i don't know if anybody's googled
net worth is
accurate no mine says like 250 thousand
dollars
is that accurate it's not
are you ready for our next story they
also say 140 pounds which accurate is
accurate
are you ready for our next story yes
olivia rodrigo clears up tawdry driver's
license love triangle rumors yes she's
been making a lot of waves in like
recent interviews she was on variety and
she was on yes this is from variety's
power of young hollywood issue she
touched upon the situation that followed
after listeners heard her song driver's
license many fans believe that the
lyrics were about the alleged
relationship between her and her high
school musical the musical series
co-star joshua bassett and sabrina
carpenter the lyrics in question said
quote and you're probably with that
blonde girl who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure about where is
my triangle your triangle is on the
table because i had to move it for
redheads i wanted to protect the
triangle it goes like this she's
everything i'm insecure
about yet today i drove through the
suburbs yeah
because
yeah yeah oh my gosh thank you our
triangles have entered the building
because how could i ever love someone
else
and i know we weren't perfect but i've
never felt use the yellow part
and i just can't imagine how you could
be so okay
now that i'm gone
okay okay continue because i actually
have thoughts
this is what she said she explained
saying quote i put it out not knowing it
would get the that reaction so it was
really strange when it did i just
remember everyone being so weird and
speculative about stuff they had no idea
about i don't really subscribe to hating
other women because of boys i think
that's so stupid and i really resent
that narrative that was being tossed
around
okay i have a lot to say because first
of all
of course you didn't know the song was
going to blow up in the way that it did
there was no way for her to know that uh
green and i do agree that like we are so
beyond the narrative of women hating
women for stealing their boyfriends for
sure
but
i think the miss olivia needs to take a
smidgen of responsibility here because
first of all if it's not about this
situation
which it was so like the picture was
painted so clear for us so if it wasn't
i do feel as though she did not one
thing to stop this narrative if that was
really the case and
if this wasn't about sabrina carpenter
and literally people descended upon upon
sabrina carpenter and olivia rodrigo did
nothing that's even worse yeah and she
really does like sabrina so she's
alluding to maybe here that like the
the fans got the narrative wrong
and i don't think that we did i don't
think that we did either and if we did
someone could have cleared that up a
while ago and she should have do you
think i do think she never expected this
song to go where it did and even if the
song became mildly popular like i bet
like her best hope for the song i mean
it definitely exceeded every expectation
that she could have had or dreamed of
but
even if the song became a little popular
no one was going to be digging into the
lyrics and like finding stuff out yeah
so
it's i mean it's possible that we got it
wrong and that sabrina carpenter
unjustly like received like the tail end
of teenage
angst
but that's almost worse if that's the
case because that would mean olivia
rodrigo did nothing to stop the
unnecessary
bullying of sabrina carpenter that i
don't i don't know what's worse i just
don't think we got it wrong i think
maybe here she's trying to say that like
we missed not we the mess i have no part
in this
you you people that you miss the message
and like it's more so about this boy
that broke her heart not that about the
girl not the girl that he's with now but
i think that of all the
emotions that came out of the fans after
this song i would say 95 were directed
at joshua bassett and like five percent
were like sabrina carpenter being the
blond girl yeah i do think that like
okay if we're talking about driver's
license yes if we're talking about deja
vu like that song was really mean like
that's so good really mean like
so good
but it's just like
it's a mean song to sabrina yeah it's
it's a worse song to sabrina than it is
to joshua
yeah well she's pretty much calling him
like a phony but she's also saying to us
like your whole relationship is fake
like i did it i had your man first i
[ __ ] him first like yeah yeah like
it's really taunting him you know
yeah so i don't know i
i'm kind of like
disappointed in this bizarre response
but then sabrina song's skin is also a
little bit like and i'm [ __ ] him now
right well
it was a rebuttal it was a rebuttal i
love i'm just saying devil's death i
just want to say i love every song that
has come out of this situation we're so
spoiled with good music yeah and but i
just do wonder like how sabrina's doing
i think she's probably doing well are
they together are they together that's
the question i don't know
it's just the craziest
teenage love story
yeah
are you ready for our next story our
next three stories are some casting news
that you guys just have to know about
okay so should i intro the casting news
brought to you by
movement yeah you really should in the
tiny apartment in southern california
two college dropouts teamed up to create
a watch company that broke all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors and
clean original designs movement grew
into one of the fastest growing watch
brands shipping to over 160 countries
across across the globe and now they've
expanded into blue light glasses that
protect your eyes from screens
minimalist jewelry and style essentials
that don't break the bank all designed
out of their california headquarters
so by the way i love blue light glasses
and it's so hard to find ones that don't
make you look like your grandfather
wearing bifocals and the movement ones
are sickening and it's great to do
before bed so like blue light can keep
you up yeah if you don't wear blue light
glasses it also can cause headaches
which you know we're always trying to
avoid and they have fabulous styles and
unbeatable prices movement watches have
the look and quality of four to five
hundred dollar watches but your pet that
you would pay for at a department store
but you are paying a fraction of the
price because they're built online and
they own the process from start to
finish and you just get a watch shipped
right to your door for free and if you
don't love it you can ship it right back
for free so if you they make stunning
watches for men and women it's i
actually recently got one for ben for um
his birthday it's a great gift for
someone in your life because you always
need to know what time it is
and with the blue time is it summer time
and i got myself a pair of blue light
glasses because if you're spending all
day in front of your computer on the
blue light filtering glasses that i got
are the ever scroll they're a game
changer and they really help with eye
strain poor sleeping patterns and
they're really modern and the styles are
stunning so if you want to elevate your
look with style that doesn't break the
bank then join the movement and get 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt.com
again that's mvmt.com
toast to get 15 off with free shipping
and free returns thank you claudia our
next story is some apt casting news
beanie feldstein will star in funny
girls broadway revival in 2022.
hey mr arnstein
here she
is
really good thank you the musical comedy
funny girl will play broadway for the
first time in nearly 60 years producers
announced on wednesday and the show has
already found its wisecracking fanny
bryce beanie feldscheen feldstein
appeared in the 2017 revival of hello
dolly but she's best known for her film
roles in lady bird book smart and she's
playing monica lewinsky in the upcoming
impeachment
american crime story she'll be great in
this we all saw that picture of the back
yeah she'll be great i'm so excited to
watch that
so she's going to be amazing and this is
just like a really exciting time for
beanie everything's coming up beanie
everything's coming
beanie
um of course when this news was released
people were kind of quaking for leah
michelle because
first of all
i just have to say like i'm really glad
that they chose someone who's jewish
like it's just an important part of the
role and i'm very grateful to the
broadway producers so everyone was kind
of like you know if there ever was gonna
be a broadway revival it's actually a
storyline on glee there finally is a
funny girl revival on broadway and of
course leah michelle goes out for the
part in the show and her whole you know
being is inspired by barbra streisand
she never gets her nose job because
barbra streisand never did and so when i
think like modern barbara streisand i do
think leah michelle do you i didn't have
that thought i was mostly just thinking
of you oh that's so nice because that
song um
is my favorite claudia's party trick and
by the way don't rain on my parade um
lee michelle sings in the first season
of glee and it's like a show-stopping
when i sing domain in my parade i
actually sing the glee version like yeah
it's so good so
a lot of people were talking about this
like why didn't she get the part what do
you think why didn't she get the part
well i do think she's been enraptured in
a little bit of scandal over the last
couple years and i don't think people
you know want to be associated with that
because of the reading thing no she had
like her whole drama
what was the drama again she was accused
of right of like bullying and bullying
and like tar like targeting a lot of the
poc oh my god yes i totally forgot about
it and then like her sponsors dropped
her and then she kind of went off and
she's kind of like
off the record not off the radar off the
radar she's releasing an album but she's
much living a much more low-key life
okay i completely forgot yes so
i think that's one reason i don't i mean
honestly
this is like this is news i'm very
interested in because i do wish they did
like some sort of open casting call
because like my ass would have went like
i wouldn't have gotten the part because
i have no formal training but like i
would have went just like the story and
i would have vlogged it for patreon
but
but
i have a lot of hope for beanie i'm
excited for her she does have a broadway
background i do think that's important i
think she's jewish i think that's also
important she has the look you know
but we've never heard i've never heard
her sing
i have she sings on ben platt's
instagram all the time
and she's good yeah yeah she's like
classically trained you know
but i just want to say one caveat
i do think that
it's important when casting a fanny
bryce
to cast someone who gives off fanny
bryce energy fbe
and i do not think beanie feldstein
i never would have chosen her for this
role like i never even would have
thought of her as a fanny bryce energy
kind of gal lee michelle obviously comes
to mind with the fannie bryce energy
she's radiating it throughout her body
so that's what i'll say like i just i'm
excited blah blah yeah but i don't know
if she gives off fbe but i will be going
to opening night alternatively in
thinking about it i don't know
everything that constitutes fbe
but when i think back to like having
watched the movie and like you know
barbra streisand's character she was
like pretty quirky and like
awkward and like all of these things and
also like
extroverted and like rambunctious right
but i do think the 2021 version of that
is beanie feldstein i'm not interested
in the 2021 version like no funny girl
is
like needs to be no but like that quirky
not like other girls type of thing
i think it's beanie i mean i just feel
like you
i just feel like you're not beanie's
biggest fan
what do you mean no i love i mean first
of all she could have been related to
ruthie so that's one thing
okay
and it's such an honor and i guess like
part of me yes part of me is jealous no
well yeah obviously but no part of me is
like
thinks it should have been liam michelle
like wholeheartedly like it's
it's all it's so the fact that like the
internet lea michelle was trending all
day yesterday the fact that this news
came out and people immediately
associated leah michelle with it is
widely and michelle
should get the role yeah do you know
what i mean i do know about you there's
such an association between lea michelle
and fanny bryce slash barbra streisand
she herself said personally like she
when she was a nice well she never got a
nose job you know all that [ __ ] like
yeah
i don't know i just think that's what
i'm saying by the fanny price energy
like an association like i never when i
think fanny bryce i don't think beanie
felt seen i'm sure that doesn't mean
she's not going to be great but just
like for the culture
i do
i would have liked to have seen liam
michelle okay is there anyone else that
you would have liked to have seen i have
to think about it because it has to be
someone and i know
i'm sorry i do think it should be
someone jewish i just do think that um i
think it's an important quirk to have
for the quirky role um and obviously i
mean brunette doesn't matter i don't
know i have to think about it because
there's so many great actresses but you
also have to have a broadway background
you can't just like stumble into a
broadway show especially not as the lead
and not one like this that is so storied
yeah so it has to be someone oh honestly
it
jessica vosk would have been great
just saying i don't think she's jewish
but still you think she has been she has
yes danny bryce energy yes like a
hundred percent okay okay just a thought
okay thank you for your thoughts are you
ready for our next story which is a bit
of casting nose
noses that's apt as well
titus burgess has been cast as rooster
in nbc's upcoming annie live special
okay you guys i have been following the
casting of annie live this is what we
have yes thank you that's what i was
gonna take it from the top we announced
taraji p henson as miss hannigan 10 out
of 10. we have
harry connick jr daddy warbucks so good
what i recently found out that we
haven't spoken about yet is nicole
scherzinger will be playing grace who's
grace the assistant to daddy warbucks
who he falls in love with at the end i
like her i like nicole scherzinger um
you don't like her no that's
that's the first
kind of dent in the
really in the casting i think she'll be
so great just like dancing up on daddy
warbucks i know i just find her like
really thirsty like like on another
level of thirst okay and like i don't
know this is like a wholesome family
show
i think it's gonna have a lot of pizzazz
okay uh
i'm open to my opinion being changed but
off the bat that doesn't give me like
the apt casting butterflies okay i feel
you but it wasn't a total miss for me
which is like what i'm trying to avoid
you know okay so now we have titus
playing rooster who's ms hannigan's
brother who's you know involved in the
plan to snatch annie it's actually you
know annie we i look back on that light
show like not not sure the movie very
fondly but it's actually like a story of
abduction like it's actually getting
really dark twisted that final scene
where annie's climbing up that telephone
pole like trying not to get her feet
snatched by rooster like
that is the [ __ ] nightmares are made of
no a hundred percent and i can't believe
those kids we used to be like it's a
hard nut and like and he's in the back
of a telephone pole getting abducted no
it's like it's a hard knock life yeah
we're living with an alcoholic who's so
emotionally abusive towards us right no
and like and her brother creepy brothers
like always trying to like grab us yeah
no annie is actually like a really dark
story it is but with such a happy ending
and such a good soundtrack yeah what's
your favorite song for manny
there are so many there are so many bet
your bottom dollar tomorrow's fantastic
i also love
easy street
easy street
and that's what that was a sexy little
like shoulder sexy song that do it again
sister and brother hannigan sing
the movie also has incest
easy stream
shoulder
easy stream
i'm too cool
too cool
easy street and then also when annie
sings maybe like talking about how maybe
show me your baby he's rich it's so good
so good maybe he'll make me and then
also
the reboots have really good and i mean
just the ceo opportunity
and also and you're never fully dressed
without a smile and sia did a reboot of
that's a cover of that song wow i
actually never really sat down and
thought about how many good songs of
course the sun will come out tomorrow
and hard life always come to mind but i
forgot about maybe oh my god so many the
you're never fully dressed i think i'm
gonna
like get here
wow you know what what is the original
annie like this the one that we watched
yeah that kid is [ __ ] cute
yeah where is she now i don't know she's
i don't know still traumatized from that
telephone pole scene i know i was as a
kid yeah no that was crazy stuff but
punjab to the rescue wait okay um can
you give me her name that little annie
i'm like kind of obsessed with her okay
but now like searching annie original
cast actually hopefully i'll get the and
that dress that dress should be in the
museum that dress is iconic but then
also
they're
have they cast any yet no they haven't
cast any and that's what's gonna make or
break okay the original annie her name
was aileen quinn and now she's 50 years
old wow i feel old but
there was another annie the one with
kathy
yes and that annie was mad cute too and
then they also have let's go to the
movies by the way let's you know that
you missed a major
claudia what the craziest news has just
surfed but the kathy bates annie is who
i need to confirm i need to sadie
claudia i need to confirm with my
sources because it could be the craziest
what crossover
we've ever seen can we also just really
quickly last time we were casting annie
for the the live we said that that
redhead girl from
um
stranger things would be great if she
was younger and i just want to say i
found out afterwards that she actually
did play like annie on broadway or
off-broadway
what is the news you're freaking me out
the news is that the person who played
annie in the kathy bates version her
name is alicia morton
but tell me
but tell me that's not alicia whit from
the hallmark channel
but her name is alicia morton right so i
feel like maybe they use the wrong
picture or something
they definitely use the wrong picture
they're tripping me out you're telling
me that the hallmark girl was annie no
way
there's no time doesn't make sense
because that woman's like 40 and annie
wasn't 35 years ago the kathy bates
version it might have been it was a long
time it was like from the 90s
hold on but there's alicia with alicia
morton they're two different people okay
you guys this is a conspiracy i think
google might have mixed up their photos
because i'm like really quaking the
movie was from 1999. yeah so that's 20
plus years ago so she's not 27. no it's
not
i'm sorry
i need to figure this out for myself
let's check her imdb was she in the
christmas switch no what was mary very
mary makes up
no okay forget it i wanted that to be i
wanted that for you oh my gosh that was
a lot that was really a lot for me okay
but so back to
who plays annie is that i don't think
that there's any child actor out right
now who it'll have to be someone new
wait this previous annie we have to
re-watch it is so star-studded we know
kathy bates plays miss hannigan victor
garber plays daddy
iconic alan [ __ ] plays rooster i
believe
kristen chenoweth please i think
rooster's girlfriend
lily saint something oh my god
sarah hyland plays molly
stop the other orphan audra mcdonald
plays grace you guys we have to rewatch
this so i wonder when i when i reference
the annie that i watched as a kid i
wonder if it's the original or if it's
victor garber we really watched both can
i see the annie from 1999
yes
and he's such a great story and that's
what i'm saying it's so layered
gotta gotta listen to the soundtrack
this was the annie from 99 oh god they
took me to amazon oh my gosh it's so
hard to find annie you know
annie
facts need to start a website called
anniefacts.com
okay that poster is really bad oh my god
wait um victor garber was bald i forgot
yeah i feel like
the one that i watched is the original
like i remember her being like a curly
haired little we watched both they were
really so different and that in that one
she's like talking to fdr the president
like sing to him and then in this one is
when they go to the movies and they have
the tap dancing for let's go too we
should really just kind of do like a
back to back like annie marathon
original annie 1999 annie quiven jay
wallace annie just to get ready for the
live annie right i don't know when live
annie is coming and i just i'm sure
whoever they cast as annie is going to
be someone that we don't know i hope um
yeah it should be right this is no one
out there right now it has to be a
natural redhead i'm sorry i think that
it should be a redhead still
yeah no like annie i'm available
no but i was gonna say you weren't
listening to me because you were on your
alicia wit journey there's a conspiracy
they're the same person is that when
when we look back at like photos of you
as a kid like you really really really
could have played andy like you had the
hair like you had everything mm-hmm do
you feel resentful at all that you
didn't no not for one moment yeah yeah
yeah i just
enjoyed my life up until this point you
know i wouldn't change a thing no
offense
wow okay well it's a movie so they could
have done voiceover that's true
okay so that's your annie news for the
day as always we will keep you posted i
can't believe i didn't know about nicole
scherzinger
i know
that that casting news just slipped
through the cracks yeah are you ready
for our fifth and final story it's the
casting news we've all been waiting for
it's the final story
[Music]
oh my god the screens on youtube and
flipping back and forth so quickly
amazing amazing the final story is the
casting news that we have all been
waiting for
the question of the year
who will replace alex trebek has been
answered mike richards has been named
the new permanent jeopardy host and
claudia's favorite person mayam bialik
has been tapped to host a spin-off
series oh
jeopardy executive producer mike
richards was announced as the permanent
host of the syndicated game show on
wednesday about nine months after the
death of longtime host alex trebek
additionally mayim bialik has been
topped to tap to host jeopardy primetime
and spin-off series including the just
announced jeopardy national college
championship an all-new tournament which
will air in primetime on abc in 2022. so
mayan be alex just doing the spin-off
and then the college yeah mike richards
is the new alex trebek there's no more
like
it's aaron rodgers one day and jennings
ken jennings the next so let's talk
about this because i never would have he
was not even on my radar first of all
right
um but
i have to say i do think this is
actually a good selection i'm usually
there's so much hype for this and people
are always disappointed but we have been
really
kind of analyzing what it takes to be
the next alex trebek and i actually
think weirdly like the answer was right
in front of us you know i feel i
definitely had less
invested in this decision than you did
but i feel really at peace with this
choice like i really like that it's
someone who just like alex trebek will
will be known for jeopardy and only
jeopardy and even his career up until
this point has been so jeopardy focused
i just this is my first time seeing a
picture of him he's very handsome very
handsome i also think that like his very
close relationship with alex trebek is a
lovely
sentiment moving forward i think he
understands tv i think he knows how to
read a teleprompter like i think that
no better
person could have been chosen honestly
which is crazy like which is crazy i
mean it's the job a million girls would
kill for and it's a it's really like a
beautiful ending to this kind of
story and it's a full circle moment yeah
i agree
and it's just like it was also like the
answer the announcement was very low-key
like at first it was so much hype but of
course as time was on people move on and
now i just feel like we'll slowly just
start to
move into the age of mike richards yeah
he put he said it in a statement i'm
deeply honored to have the opportunity
to host the syndicated version of
jeopardy never in my wildest dreams
could i have imagined being chosen to
step into a role of this magnitude i'm
incredibly humbled to step behind the
lectern and we'll work tirelessly to
make sure our brilliant contestants
shine in each and every episode that's
true it's about the contestants like
right the host is just sort of the
engine but it's not about a razzle
dazzle host that's why these celebrity
episodes were somewhat flawed because of
course you're watching a celebrity aaron
rodgers like you answer the question
like what do you know about history like
that's
the exciting part but it's not about the
host it's and that's why the the formula
for who would have made the perfect
jeopardy
host is so delicate because you have to
be like interesting and smart but not
too interesting yeah and just like and
be have charisma and charm and magnitude
but also be able to kind of fade into
the background yeah and that's on being
a host yes but now hosting is so much
about being a celebrity yeah but i like
that jeopardy is sticking to its laurels
and it's gonna remain pretty similar
yeah i think this is actually like i
i don't know if they're they could have
chosen someone better and i was really
kind of pro ken jennings
just because it's like a beautiful story
you know yeah like you you get so far
and that's the reward for like having
been the best in the game but i just
think personability wise he was not a it
didn't happen for him
you know i like that it's
they threw us a curveball yeah and it's
it's amazing and i hope that everyone is
as universally pleased as i am because i
i really think this was just
amazing and the answer was right in
front of us the whole time yeah also for
mayan be alex she has a phd in
neuroscience yes and she's from big bang
theory which is like um
show about science like science and like
things like that yeah sorry i didn't
want to be mean no no it's there i think
they're like
they're proud of nerds yeah i think so
but again i've never watched um it's the
worst show of all and so even that
side dish of a casting
works for me yeah me too no and i think
of all the celebrity um hosts that came
in miami was my favorite just because
she has that background like
it's an honor you know you have to earn
the academic background
to i think it's great i just think it's
great yeah i'm really great so
we're three for three on app casting
news today and and that feels really
good um you know what else feels really
good what relief band
the sponsor for our tv recap segment
you've got to check out relief band the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
and it's any nausea or vomiting vomiting
why do you keep saying vomiting
i don't know it's like a new word
nausea and vomiting that can be
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more
speaking my language the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy and provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
one out of three americans regularly
suffer from nausea some of us it is
self-inflicted from a hangover some of
us it's not self-inflicted from a
migraine we've all experienced that
horrible feeling whether it's in the
backseat of a car that's you um one too
many after one too many with an after
one too many on a night out with friends
that's you or even just the anxiety of a
workday nausea can ruin the day force us
to change our plans and in the most
severe cases make us unable to function
so we've got great news because relief
band is here to check help you out and
if you're ready to take that summer road
trip hop on the boat or you're just
anxious about heading back into the
office relief ben has an exclusive offer
just for the morning toast listeners if
you go to reliefband.com and use the
promo code toast you'll receive 20 off
plus free shipping and a no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee so
head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code toast for
20 off plus free shipping thank you
claudia it's just like um i think a
self-proclaimed nausea queen yeah i just
want to let you guys know that these
things work they really do and so if
you're looking for some relief which if
you're like me you always are relief
bands for relief you're very like
temperamental like on a boat on
absolutely rental and it's like the
older i get the worse the worse it gets
like now like of course anytime we have
a long car ride like i'm putting on
those bad boys and i'm saying some
prayers if there's any like
sickness worse than nausea no
probably maybe like diarrhea diarrhea
sucks
no i don't mean like terminal illness i
just mean like what's worse like having
a sore throat or nausea not just the
[ __ ] worst
yeah or a headache migraine yeah that's
bad too they're all really bad but at
least some of them we have coping
mechanisms like relief band um okay real
housewives of beverly hills we wrapped
up our trip to palm springs and the
ladies headed back to la but not before
seeing a tawdry expose in the la times
which of course is a big deal but i
think like as a lawyer in l.a it's like
the biggest deal ever right so i just
want to say i've watched all the
episodes that we haven't recapped i
watched them all yesterday so they are
all kind of like one for me yeah we
haven't discussed like
the car accident
oh you're so behind it was not turned we
haven't we haven't discussed it like the
whole trajectory of erica's i want to
say performance on this trip yeah but i
think regardless of whether or not she's
guilty or innocent she has to treat this
as a performance you know what i mean
like
and i do think that that's where sutton
is going with what she's trying to say
which is like i think we're being used
as and like this could be like
part of evidence in a court hearing so
yes i was feeling really conflicted last
night about
about the sutton thing because part of
me
um
like hates people who just like
leave you
like the second things get tough but i
don't know sutton was spitting facts and
like
i think
it's really really hard
to prove that erica didn't know anything
like i think you know the odds
are that she definitely knew what was
going on she had 20 million dollars in
her bank account right and i'm glad we
finally got to that part because like
now i feel like we're caught up we're
caught up because that was for us the
big bombshell in housewife and the
hustler i guess we missed this la times
article right but that's the part that
really doesn't add up is the 20 million
dollars to ej global now the women are
asking the same question
so we are all caught up i mean i'm so
thankful for sutton's presence just
because it seems like she understands
the most about this case just like about
money yeah things in general money
spousal hides of money if the devil
himself puts money in your bank account
you're responsible for it right and so
sutton is just coming like right like
megan king admins like yes ready
to ask prepared
in combination with garcelle who i think
is asking like the questions that we all
want to know so let's talk about the
garcelle thing i actually really felt so
[ __ ] bad for her horrible because i
believe crystal when she says like you
were not around when she told us not to
bring it up i was kind of
interested in why garcelle brought it up
three times after like she was really
like trying to
i don't know what her intention was
behind bringing it up so many times but
i don't think she
intentionally betrayed erica's trust no
i don't think she intentionally betrayed
erica's trust i do think the reaction
was a lot but sometimes it's the thing
that sets you off and then you can't
come back from it which i i wasn't
jackie i was gonna when i was watching i
was like i'm gonna i was preparing what
i was gonna say today i'm like you know
you never know what's gonna set you off
whatever she's going through tough time
but no but my only fault with the whole
scene i have no fault with garcelle i
even have no fault with howard cause
she's a mess she is a locker is
luciferina is lisa brenna who was
literally so excited that garcelle
slipped up yeah that she said something
that she shouldn't have that the way
that lisa arena is going about it
sitting there in her coat like and
acting if what like i hate that this
happened like i hate that like like
i
it was so annoying bothersome and did
you watch watch what happens live last
night she was on lisa noah
and gary gennetti and andy the first
question he asked which was which is
what everyone's saying and what i keep
thinking is like where is the energy
that you brought to denise that you
brought in
that you know we need we're on a show we
need to ask the questions it's going to
come up blah blah blah and she was like
one she was like you know i tried to
learn from my behavior last season and
then liar right and that's not you know
what i'm gonna do again and two do i
have to put this show on my back andy
there's eight other women like but so we
but someone asked a question and you
just literally made her feel so horrible
about it oh my god i literally cannot i
cannot stand no but the thing is i was
gonna say it's like you never know
what's going to set you off i don't
think it was really what garcelle did i
just think it was like a lot but then
when i think of this whole journey her
performance on the show
i think the timing is so interesting
because she got off a clamped and then
she left and went home or else she would
have been around the women when that la
times article came out or the article
came out really early in the morning she
would have been at her hotel and she
wouldn't have shown up for the day
i think either way it would have been
fine no i just think like a lot of what
her reaction with garcelle had to do
with was her needing to get out of there
as well
interesting you have a heads up when an
article that big is coming out about you
they reach out for comments
i guess i mean it is really convenient
that she left right before i think she
would have left anyway like i don't
think she was ever discussing that
article on the day dropped with the
girls no but i think the fact that she
was you know
100 miles away was
intentional
yeah
yeah
and see like lisa rinna and i you know i
respect you being a good friend but like
lisa arena when they all get to denise's
house
no
not daddy sorry uh it's
doritos oh this is for denise justice
for nice when they all go to darit's
house
she's like yeah i spoke to erica this
morning like she that should have been
filmed you know like she is really
really protecting erica and like love
love a good friend but like at what cost
yeah i
i do go back and forth like if this is
your best friend and you obviously
like believe her believe her then you
should have her back
but not just without asking like a few
basic questions considering the crimes
that they're being accused of are so
atrocious that's why i feel like the
person who i believe is handling this in
the most
ethical way while also trying to be a
good friend is kyle like kyle's asking
like 20 million dollars like that's a
it's a fair [ __ ] question like up
until this point it's always been like
excuse me the narrative is like how
could tom have brought erica into this
and now it's like wait was erica already
there and so it's it's
a very fair question that our friends
are asking and i feel like sun's the one
being like the most realistic about it
because like what the [ __ ] did she oh
erica she met her last year like she's a
woman who obviously cares about her
reputation she's like i wanna be
associated with this [ __ ] like oh wait
said the meanest thing on watch what
happens live she said um
you know something something came up
about like sutton not wanting to like
associate whatever and she was like i
mean i have businesses and i would still
want to like you know be around erica
like sutton doesn't it's not like she
has a business that she has to
and and he was like what about the store
she's like sure she has a store but like
what businesses does lisa i guess like
lisa dusters and beauty that's as much
of a business as sutton's retail store i
just want to say yeah anyways she was
just like doing
so much so it seems like there's
somewhat of a divide in the group and
that's what garcelle was saying she's
like okay you told me this intimate
piece of information and i'm not even a
part of your inner circle and there is
this inner circle of lisa erica kyle to
read and it's teddy they call themselves
like the fab five like there is this
inner circle of women so i can
understand garcelle bringing up
something private like if garcelle knows
all the other women must know i'm not
even really that close with erica so i
don't feel like garcelle had any bad
intentions and i felt like really bad
for her like it was just like a terrible
moment but i just did kind of think it
was weird how many times she brought
that up oh i thought she but she just
brought it up once and then she brought
it up twice
how before the women sat down on the
couch and after
oh and she brought it up twice so it was
just like weird like why keep bringing
up i guess yeah that is a little funky
but i do find this whole like inner
circle thing to be really interesting
and definitely true like all those women
who were in the inner circle were just
on that boat with teddy like singing
expensive to be me like there is this
and i kind of feel like i'm leaning more
towards being on the side of like
crystal garcelle and sutton me too where
it's just like it's black and white like
did you do this [ __ ] or not like yeah
but if you they don't they're friends
with erica they don't over anything
right but if you were to
believe for some reason that she didn't
then wouldn't you have her back
yeah but
facts are facts like 20 million dollars
yeah i'm just like ever since you
pointed this thing out like i cannot
watch this show without getting
infuriated like where's the energy
where's the denise energy where's the
denison energy for actual crimes that
were committed not something personal
about your sexuality like you had so
much energy to out denise as being
bisexual
which is so unethical by the way um and
made her like into such a villain
but there's no energy just to kind of
ask the difficult questions to your
friend erica about whether or not she
took money from burn victims i will say
orphans and widows i will say that they
haven't seen erica since they found that
out that's true we haven't so she's kind
of but this whole time it's been orphans
no but this whole time it was just like
before before we
knew about the 20 million no no no not
even that there was a time when she was
getting divorced where there's legal
drama with tom there's always legal
drama with tom is erica complicit that
we didn't know
that these were like crimes with the
most vulnerable victims right
and i think you think it's a white cop
that's what um right so that was it
until
they were like okay you're getting a
divorce from a very powerful man who's
also embroiled in legal drama like a
very just tough situation
and then the article dropped where they
put everything together and it's like
it's bad bad and very very sad and they
have not seen her since so i'm just
going to give them and it looks like
next week when they have this like
dinner party um yeah it looks like
people start asking questions so that's
what i'm waiting for but up until this
point
it wasn't
as
nefarious as we know now that it is i
guess like how we move forward will be
very telling but also knowing what we
know now we know that
dorit
kyle no yeah derek and lisa all like are
standing with eric right so whatever has
transpired they've chosen to believe her
i just wonder you know let's watch them
ask the questions okay and maybe the way
that erica has convinced them or shown
to them that she's we'll convince us
we'll convince us too yeah because i
guess at this point in the show they've
all read the article
which has all the information that was
in the most recent documentary so we
know exactly what the women know right
now and moving forward
it will be more interesting because up
until this point it was like tom tom tom
yeah and it was just like erica is going
through a divorce that's very sad yeah
but what eric is actually going through
is much more serious
okay um also love island was on last
night it was just the episode where
people meet their families and it was
all over zoom and it was so incredibly
boring and it was just like awkward and
weird the only kind of
interesting thing was literally the
episode was so like the whole thing was
like me the family commercial and the
last couple was obviously will and kira
will is just like acting like he's
actually kind of sociopathic like acting
like everything's fine like wasn't even
embarrassed to like meet the family of a
girl he cheated on like it was so
sociopathic
and then he got up to leave and she
spoke to her family and her dad was like
we honestly really did not want to come
on here and like do this but you know we
wanted to support you we wanted to see
you her sister was crying here was
crying they were like just saying they
don't trust will and like this whole
time they're having this conversation
the editors are so shady they're
splicing up will recapping his
conversation with his family and kira's
family with andre in the kitchen he's
like here is so happy i'm so happy cut
to cure crying oh so amazing curious
family loves me i love hira's family my
dad told her to come to our house
medellin cartoon care crying um then she
finally hangs up with her family he's
still talking about how happy they are
she's like she literally hides under the
stairs and is hysterically crying cut
too well in the kitchen oh we're so
happy together it's gonna be so good and
she did she had a conversation with him
she was like
i
want to know like what are your
intentions like we want to be boyfriend
girlfriend right now get married have
kids like are you ready to like have a
committed relationship like when we
leave here if you go to a bar like we
don't have to put a label on it but like
if we go to a bar and somebody asked if
you have a girlfriend like you're gonna
say no like and he was just like slow
slow slowly slow down so really a lot of
red flags and it turned it looks like to
tonight
he sits trina down for a conversation
kind of remember how he like sat shannon
down and all the blame oh kyra's having
skeptical thoughts it must be because of
you shannon now he's putting it on trina
and i draw the [ __ ] line at trina he
and trina is like
are you [ __ ] kidding me like so i
think although it's very difficult to
pinpoint what it is about will that's
weird it's becoming a lot more clear
what that is amazing i mean sad but like
i'm glad that we're getting clarity so
now it's like who's gonna win is it
olivia and cory no or is it andre and
trina
if olivia and cory win i will never
watch the show again i know
i would want andre and trina win i would
have alana and charlie charlie win i
think if jeremy and
bailey win it's
it's not good either yeah okay but i
just have to say like i'm really in tune
with the love island usa like team
um on reddit i've been reading a lot and
like they are who are they all voting
for trina and andre because they just
think trina is a queen who deserves
justice i 100 agree and they think that
they should be the first season where
one person wins like the money because
andre just got here and trina has been
like oh right it could just be one
person but wouldn't
wouldn't andre have to say
he would have to say split and treated
would have to say keep right
in order for trina to keep it yeah but
he could say keep and trina could say
keep and then what happens neither of
them get it
if if he said he would be the most hated
man in america but then he and then he
would have nothing to show for it
if he said yeah yeah he doesn't he can
only say split if but i don't see trina
saying keep because like she should i'm
sorry like she no no you're worth trina
that's really true because they didn't
realize they could intentionally make it
so that just the one most deserving
queen wins and do you think that like
people who are in couples like are
having those conversations like if we
win what are we gonna do do you think
they're allowed to like
i think they're allowed to i think those
conversations must happen yeah because
like will and kiera probably up until
this point thought they were winning and
they were just like making plans like
let's blip slowly or
will was gonna steal from kira yeah like
maybe that's what he was doing he's in
this perfect couple he doesn't want [ __ ]
out of the house right but he's about to
win 100 000 for himself because he knows
cure would say split i always keep
forgetting about the money like that
that's what this [ __ ] is about it's
really a weird wrench that they throw
into it and i do feel like it should be
more than a hundred thousand dollars i
don't know but if you it's like
it's an entertaining amount because it's
like if just one person wins that amount
of money like that's amazing but if you
split it after taxes it's like 30 grand
it's pretty selfless to split it like
you have to really love that person like
i love you more than fifty thousand
dollars oh josh and shannon did an
instagram live with cinco and cash and
then giovanni joined and sean shannon
and josh were just like all over each
other like they're like a legit ass
couple we'd love to see it and they
should be able to win
yeah no but i'm going for trina oh yeah
me too
i don't know when we vote so if the
finale's on sunday we probably vote on
friday yeah
it'll be very exciting
that's so crazy but the episode i'm not
gonna lie like was really boring seeing
people talk through a screen it's just
like it's not gonna cut it like the show
has been so premium up until that point
like we're better than that like if you
can't fly them out just forget it yeah
especially when no one's in a couple
except for will and kira like i'm sure
that was really she probably was so
awkward she probably needed to speak to
her family though she probably feels
like so stupid confused and just lonely
yeah especially because like i think her
really good friends were shannon and
cache and yeah and like olivia and trina
are being there for her because they're
obviously the ogs but i don't think it's
like a really true friendship yeah
i agree and i'm just like not
the more episodes we watch the less i'm
buying what olivia is selling
thank you yeah thank you um
okay so tonight love island is on but
like i'm going out so i'll probably are
yeah i have a cocktail party oh my gosh
cocktails yeah
that's so cool what's the plan it's um
where are we going sure it's um ben's
friend's jack's birthday oh fun and it's
a cocktail party yeah i mean the
invitation said cocktail which i thought
like cocktail tire no like cocktail like
it actually just said cocktail on
limitation like we're having cocktails
which is such like an adult thing but i
guess he is like turning 30. so so
cocktails it is cocktails it is cool
next stop retirement home
um so that's where i'll be so i probably
won't recap love island unless like i
happen to like have a lame night get
home early but i just don't see that for
myself i don't see that for you and you
deserve a fun night and i think we'll
we'll probably get like a hangover
episode tomorrow
okay that's always fun for a friday i
think i'm gonna bring brew tomorrow
because every day this week i've wanted
to bring him but like i've had something
afterwards okay i won't break theo and i
just you guys have to see brew it's been
so long he's such an amazing he's so big
he's such an amazing little boy and
his birthday's in three days oh my god
and you know what today is it's a
four-year anniversary of me bringing
theo home
wow my up showed me like me and ben at
the airport pick him up it was august
12th are you sure yeah that's crazy
because and then i remember our wedding
was a month later and we sent him to
like some camp for two weeks it was the
hardest two weeks of my life oh my gosh
so you guys i mean i don't want to make
false promises but i'm i don't know why
i might not bring brew like unless he
says mom i don't want to go no but
you're definitely going to break him i
won't break theo and i'll be here with
open arms for his auntie waiting waiting
for him oh my gosh you guys are gonna
you haven't seen brew like this in all
the time that you've known bro like he's
a brand like you've never seen him
before it's a he's a brand new man like
he's so i'm a brand new bruce we should
get rid of the plan before he comes yes
um and that's our show right our show no
one else's thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning to the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i hear
video cast box all the places wherever
you listen to the podcast my next
morning shows even faster review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
for today's society season two if you're
still here please drop an emoji on our
most recent instagram post of uh the
duck because
talks are people too have a great day
everyone bye